Passwords suck.
But passwords on mobile
are even more painful.
Hello.
My name is Maya Ben Ari,
and I'm a product manager
on the Android platform.
Let me start with a quick story.
I recently landed at the
San Francisco Airport
after an exhausting
12-hour flight.
At the baggage
claim, I had an idea.
I can order food with
my phone so it would be
waiting for me when I got home.
I quickly downloaded
an app and found
the perfect Chinese noodle dish.
I was about to submit
an order, but then I
couldn't remember my password.
I knew there would be no
food for me when I got home.
I wish it would just be easier.
And with the new
Fingerprint Support,
we're going to change that.
With Android M, we're adding
native fingerprint support
for enrollment
and device unlock.
We believe that your
device should stay secure
but would like to provide
you the best user experience
without getting in your way.
In addition, we're
introducing new APIs
for Fingerprint and
Confirm Credential
to accelerate payments
and sign-in operations.
These APIs will allow you to
utilize your fingerprint sensor
if one exists on the device.
In the Google Play
Store, if a user
has a registered
finger on her device,
she can choose to use it
to confirm her purchases.
When she wants to
buy a song, she
can simply tap her
finger on the sensor
to complete the purchase.
This is all made possible with
the new FingerprintManager
class.
This simple API allows the app
to authenticate the user using
his or her fingerprint.
The app perceives an
authentication callback
from the sensor once the
finger has been detected.
The API will authenticate the
user each time the app requests
an authentication call.
The API utilizes KeyStore
to create and use
cryptographic keys.
FingerprintManager gives
full control of the UI
to app developers.
It allows apps to natively
integrate fingerprint
into their flow.
In this example, the target app
is using the fingerprint APIs
to confirm users'
online purchases.
A user can add
items to his cart.
And when he's
ready to check out,
he can confirm using his finger.
For consistency across app,
we recommend using the Android
Fingerprint Icon.
To summarize, our
Fingerprint APIs
can be used to accelerate
online payments
and sign-in operations.
It authenticates the user each
time the app requests to do so,
while providing
the app developer
full control over the UI.
FingerprintManager is great for
authenticating per transaction.
But what if you want to know how
recently the user has unlocked
his phone?
With our new Confirm
Credential API,
you can leverage the
user's lock screen
for authenticating the user.
Here I have a phone
which has been modified
to add a fingerprint sensor.
To pay in-store with Android
Pay, the next generation
of mobile payments, I'll tap
my phone on the terminal.
[BEEPS]
The app then checks when
I last unlocked my phone.
If I unlocked in the
last five minutes,
my payment is
considered secure, and I
can continue with my purchase.
However, if more
than five minutes
passed since I last
unlocked, the app
is not sure whether I'm
still around my device
and will prompt to authenticate.
Only after I solve my
lock screen challenge,
I can complete my purchase.
What is great is that Confirm
Credential, integrated
with Android Pay, authenticates
me only when it needs to.
Confirm Credential can
be further extended
from device unlocking
to application locking.
By leveraging the
user's lock screen
combined with the timeout
policy since user last unlocked,
the app can protect the
user's sensitive information,
such as bank details
or credit information.
For example, Credit Karma, a
credit and financial management
app, provides the user
a choice to protect
the app with her lock screen.
Next time she opens the app
after solving her lock screen
challenge, she can
quickly log into the app.
To use Confirm Credential, call
ConfirmDeviceCredentialIntent
in KeyguardManager.
With Confirm Credential, an app
can create a cryptographic key
and tie it to the device lock
screen with a timeout policy.
For example, "Did the
user unlock the device
in the last 10 minutes?"
Note that developers
can choose what
timeout they wish to require.
When the app wants to
authenticate the user,
it should first try to
use the cryptographic key.
If that fails, the app
should prompt the user
to authenticate using the
Confirm Credential API.
This will automatically
unlock the cryptographic key.
The key access timeouts are
synced across the system.
This ensures that different
apps prompt to authenticate
only when needed.
To summarize, Confirm
Credential allows an app
to create cryptographic keys
and tie those to lock screen.
It allows the
developer to specify
a timeout policy for key
access while syncing timeouts
across the system.
Our new APIs provide apps
both convenience and security.
It is up to the app
developer to decide which
solution fits him or her best.
For example, while
the Fingerprint APIs
might be better for
in-app purchases,
the Confirm Credential
might be better
for in-store purchases
or app-specific login.
To try out the APIs,
please check out
these resources which will walk
you through getting set up.
And for the next
time, I hope someone
can make it easier
for me to order food
without entering any password.
Thank you for watching.
[MUSIC PLAYING]